(audience cheering)
("Jaded")
♪ I don't wanna call and talk too long ♪
♪ I know it was wrong,
but never said I'm sorry ♪
♪ Now I've had time to think it over ♪
♪ We're much older and the
bone's too big to bury ♪
♪ Oh ♪
♪ Isn't it a shame that
it ended like that? ♪
♪ Say goodbye forever,
but you never unpacked ♪
♪ We went to hell, but
we never came back ♪
♪ I'm sorry that you're jaded ♪
♪ I could've taken you places ♪
♪ You're lonely now and I hate it ♪
♪ I'm sorry that you're jaded ♪
♪ I won't lie, it won't be easy ♪
♪ When somebody new's on your body ♪
♪ Oh oh ♪
♪ Change my number, keep your t-shirt ♪
♪ I don't mind it's torn up and faded ♪
♪ I'm sorry that you're jaded ♪
♪ I could've taken you places ♪
♪ You're lonely now and I hate it ♪
♪ I'm sorry that you're jaded ♪
(audience cheers)